do you guys want to know how bad things
are for the biden administration
here's a new poll out today
president's approval rating 34
it's what you call circling the drain
makes sense though considering
everything we've been learning this new
book written by the new york times
these guys are on a roll this week
blows the lid off all this behind the
scenes drama at the white house
and a lot of it's coming from kamala
harris she's like the antonio brown of
the white house
total diva
we told you yesterday about how kamal
and joe aren't really on the best terms
their weekly lunches are really awkward
it's two people sitting at a table
totally silent
we actually got some video of the launch
watch
[Music]
it's really bad i mean this is just a
taste
of the buffet of grievance are you ready
apparently this is according to the time
so it has to be real
kamala is fed up with joe biden's mostly
white inner circle
they they don't give her any respect she
says it's probably because they're
racist because they're white
and she's really mad that people don't
respond like this when she enters the
room
[Music]
[Applause]
to be fair kamala only demands people
stand for
i mean who does she think she is british
royalty
i mean to be honest with all the
complaining she's done about her new
life in the spotlight
she kind of comes off a little meghan
markley
oh and apparently ready her vogue
magazine cover
total meltdown over it
this one right here we're about to show
you
published two weeks before the
inauguration kamala didn't like the
picture
because she was wearing sneakers
she put the sneakers on she tied the
sneaker shoes but she didn't like that
they were on the cover
she said she wanted to look more
established
well
then this
that title we've given her the borders
are
she hates it
she wants to be in charge
of relations with the nordic countries
instead of the northern triangle
she would have rather been
sent to i don't know copenhagen or oslo
instead of central america she was very
mad about that and apparently the white
house laughed at her when she said that
i mean it does explain her obsession
with root causes
we are focused on addressing both the
acute factors
and the root causes the root causes
after taking a leadership role on root
causes the actual root causes invest in
the root causes the overall issue which
is root causes on the root causes you
can't just react to a problem without
solving it
at its roots at its root
in case you missed it
i bring all this up to say this joe
kambla
if you guys want to be on the winning
team
we have to get rid of all this drama
come on you're better than this
kellyanne conway is the former counselor
to the president
she joins us now kellyanne have you ever
seen anything like this before
no and certainly not with the president
and vice president that i worked with
trump and pence i mean for all the
hullabaloo about their relationship over
the last year or year plus the biden
kamala harris one is the real one of
intrigue where the staffers are at each
other's throats where they don't get
along i was in those lunches here and
there with the president the vice
president they had a weekly lunch trump
and pence every monday unless there was
a scheduling conflict and they would
invite different ones of us in
uh and look a couple things are going on
here
jill biden jill biden was right about
kamala harris but for the wrong reasons
jill biden famously said f her
about kamala harris to a group of
supporters the day after the debate in
which kamala harris basically called joe
biden the racist but made it about her
as a little girl and jill biden famously
said in the book that was released last
may
f her about kamala harris um so she she
was right to be upset according to the
jonathan martin and alex burns book joe
biden was right to be upset that her
husband chose connell harris but it
turns out she was prescient i mean this
is a person who has
the common house has no seriousness of
purpose no reassurance to this country
no emotional connection to her people it
seems like and don't take it from me
take it from her own staff of which
there's been an exodus jesse just this
past monday doesn't make the news
because it's so common now just monday
two days ago kamla harris's national
security advisor resigned and she's an
expert in eastern europe she was the
ambassador to bulgaria before she and
and so this happens all the time
including her african-american staffers
by the way have have left her her comms
director her press secretary all these
different people have left her and and
it's for a very simple reason she just
can't do the job and america is looking
at this and see this and kamala harris
jesse waters and kellyanne conway have
at least one thing in common
each of us received zero electoral votes
last time last presidential election
this woman could not get a single
electoral vote from the democrats how in
the world did the rest of us get stuck
with her if you're amy klobuchar even if
you're elizabeth warren two very
articulate very well-spoken very um
compelling women wrong on the issues of
course but they they went farther and
came closer to being the nominee than
kamala harris did and we're totally
passed over for vp for this woman who
can't do the job jesse your children and
my children school children can memorize
things times tables spelling lists
um the pledge of allegiance the vice
president united states can memorize
something and make us all feel reassured
that she's smart and up to the task this
has not happened yet
it has not
and we're all waiting for it to happen
but i don't think it's ever going to
happen
kellyanne conway thank you so much for
your analysis as always
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else